c'était une semaine après les attaques
du 11 septembre le président bush
lançait officiellement la chasse à
l'homme dans le far west on avait
coutume de placardé un avis de recherche
qui disait recherché mort ou vif
tout ce que je veux et tout secret
mairie à veux c'est qu'on l'amène devant
l'estonie arrêté oussama ben laden et
démanteler son réseau
tel était l'objectif de l'intervention
militaire américaine en afghanistan
après un an de traque malgré des
semaines de bombardements à tora bora au
nord-est du pays le chef présumé du
réseau al qaïda reste introuvable
le sénat américain demande des comptes à
l'administration bush
nous n'avons toujours pas tuer ni
capturer oussama ben laden est ce que
vous savez au moins où il est bien
évidemment les états unis ne savent pas
où il est en savons que rencontrent de
grandes difficultés de fonctionnement
il est peut-être mort il est peut-être
blessé il est peut-être en afghanistan
il est peut-être quelques pareil
d'oussama ben laden les américains n'ont
trouvé en afghanistan qu'un
enregistrement vidéo une cassette qui
auraient été découvertes par hasard à
djalal abad dans son quartier général
déserté sur cette vidéo de mauvaise
qualité rendue publique par le pentagone
le 13 décembre dernier
on y voit ben laden rencontrant un
cheikh saoudien venu lui apporter son
soutien
une rencontre riche en commentaires sur
les attentats du 11 septembre nous
avions calculé à l'avance le nombre de
victimes ennemies qui serais tu es en
fonction de la position de la tour nous
avions calculé que trois ou quatre
étages serait frappé j'étais le plus
optimiste de tous grâce à mon expérience
de terrain
deux semaines après ces révélations le
chef terroriste fait apparaît à l'écran
sur la chaîne qatarie al jazeera cette
fois un enregistrement qui aurait été
expédié par avion au pakistan ben laden
y semble fatigué le visage émacié tord
le bras gauche étrangement immobile il
lance un nouvel appel à la guerre fin
comme les souffrances endurées par le
peuple palestinien
comme pour élargir sa base de soutien
puis c'est une longue éclipse de quatre
mois jusqu'à cette vidéo diffusée le 17
avril par la chaîne arabe mbc une
cassette qui aurait été enregistrée en
décembre dans laquelle ben laden se
félicite des dégâts infligés à
l'économie américaine
le 19 heures c'est au tour du sunday
times de révéler l'existence d'une
nouvelle vidéo du leader d'al qaida
obtenu par l'intermédiaire d'une agence
de presse islamique basée en angleterre
ce document daterait du mois de mars ce
qui prouverait que ben laden était
encore vivant à l'époque le chef
terroriste n'est plus réapparu depuis l
image les autorités afghanes
le croit caché au pakistan mon sentiment
c'est que le mollah omar et ben laden
sont quelque part au pakistan
ils sont certainement au nord-est de
l'autre côté de notre frontière avec le
pakistan
le 25 août dernier un site internet
islamiste publié une lettre présentée
comme émanant d'oussama ben laden
un appel à la guerre sainte lancé au
peuple afghan contre les états unis
quand un challenge un attentat a frappé
quelques jours plus tard kaboul et des
hommes tentaient d'attaquer le président
afghan hamid karzaï certains y ont vu la
signature d'al qaïda
la menace ben laden
outil d'alimenter l'époque